hello it's me Leia hi open and welcome
back to my youtube channel don't forget
to hit the subscribe button and hit the
bell so you know every single time that
I post and if you enjoy this video
definitely hit the like button and
comment below and tell me what topics
you want me to discuss next week this
week we're talking about the mind-body
connection to number one learn how to
use your mind to heal your body and
number two how to create and live a life
that you love and joining me on the line
to talk about all of this is the
absolute expert in this field dr. Phil
Parker
[Music]
[Applause]
dr. Phil Parker thank you so much for
joining me today how you doing I'm great
thank you it's so great to have you
because you spent 35 years helping
people live a life that they love
whether that be you know chasing those
dreams or whether it be to do with I'm
getting over chronic health issues and I
want to start off by looking at chronic
health issues and what kind of illnesses
are we talking about when we say okay
you know you can use your mind to heal
your body as soon as anyone says mind
body it all sounds a bit weird a bit we
were it's really not the science is
really clear now that our mind
influences our body and and in a series
of interviews that um researchers
recently kind of asking this question
you know how do you explain the mind
body and one of the big things is our
the mind and body separate because as
soon as we use mind body connection with
we're suggesting they're dead different
things and they're not the minor body
just intimately connected so as a
brilliant study they did where they got
people to drink one of those kind of
profiles to yogurts and they found when
you drink probiotic yogurt which is
affecting your gut it changes your brain
does it change in the architecture of
your brain because it's good for you for
your gut and there's the vagus nerve
that goes up to your brain and it
changes your brain so that's the first
thing second thing is as a result of the
mind affecting the body the mind has an
influence on all
physiological functions so the brain has
an influence in pretty much every
function neurotransmitters hormones
blood pressure body temperature the
speed of which your gut works your
immune system function so what I've been
looking at is is there a way to harness
that ability that we've seen where the
mind affects the body how do we use that
as well as we can we've seen it in
studies so the placebo studies that have
been done are quite amazing where they
they give people dummy pills and people
respond as if they're having the real
pill but not they just not that they
think they're better when they measure
physiological markers they're actually
changes in the way their body is working
so hard seeing that and going right how
could we use that to help people with
chronic illness so
just briefly I want to kind of just
focus on the type of illnesses just so
people just so the audience can get an
understanding of which kind of illnesses
you know they can use what we're about
to speak about you know benefit their in
lives well really because of this
mind-body connection it could be any
illness because it's about shifting your
physiology but we've worked with a whole
range of stuff so we've worked with a
lot of autoimmune diseases which is
where the immune system seems to attack
the body nobody quite knows why so they
think ms falls into that is also
neurological chronic illness we've
worked with Parkinson's we got with Emmy
and chronic fatigue we've worked with
pain muscular problems gut problems me
brains a whole range of stuff and then
we become stuck and stuck is a word that
and you've used in a lot of your
research so can you explain what this
stuck is why are people getting ill what
is happening yet look at Emmy and
chronic fatigue is a great example of
this people seems like they get some
kind of illness some virus some
bacterial infection probably again we're
not 100% sure of this and then their
body doesn't seem to go through the
normal cycle of getting bad getting
better and recovering and then moving on
what seems to happen is they somehow
they get stuck in that recovery cycle so
we've got those kind of statuses we've
also got the stuckness where the body
attacks itself in autoimmune diseases
which you shouldn't do it should be able
to distinguish foreign material from
what belongs to you and it kind of gets
locked into for keeps on forgetting that
this belongs to you it shouldn't be
being attacked you are the founder of
the lining process which looks to you a
lot of these issues like you mentioned
Emmy is one of them I want to look into
the those messages that are sent from
the brain to the body and how people can
I guess harness that and understand the
science behind it yes so the brain
communicates through the body is through
two major systems one is the nervous
systems which is like the direct wiring
and the second is hormones
produces or gets released throughout the
body and so anything you can do to get
those pathways working better to get the
the production of the hormones or the
neurotransmitters more effectively will
have it will make a difference
wishy-washy for people you know that you
new to all of this and don't know much
about that mind-body connection so when
we talk about pain for example because a
lot of your work obviously is around
that what is happening and how do people
look at interrupting this okay so pain
is much more complicated than we might
imagine we experience it all the time
the big thing about pain that all pretty
much all pain specialist will tell you
is that pain is not where you feel it
it's in your brain which is a bit weird
you know because when you poke yourself
here you feel it here but that's because
it's sending a signal down some nerve
ups and nerves to your brain where you
process it one of the problems with pain
is there's two types of Bowness there's
a cute pain when you tread on a pin and
then it's chronic pain which has been
lasting for a longer period of time and
quite often the pin has been removed the
problem is gone and we're left with this
kind of almost like this echo in the
nervous system and so looking at how do
we switch that off because there's no
point in trying to sort this bit out
that's not where the problem is the
problem is in the processing the way
that the brain seems to have forgotten
again it's got a slightly stuck it seems
to have forgotten the pain isn't there
anymore and so finding ways to - what's
the best way to dial down that pain and
in fact that's what drugs do if you take
morphine what it does is it turns down
the sensations and the processing of
those pain signals and we have onboard
things called endogenous opiates which
are naturally occurring kind of
morphine's which we can switch on if we
can learn how to do it the idea of this
fight or flight and I think particularly
right now people are incredibly stressed
you know what's going on people are
isolating so how does chronic stress
then play a part in all of this and why
is it important to us essentially you
know get on top of that
yeah it is really really important it's
it's such an in any interesting time
that we're living in and some people
will say massively threatening time
people have not asked me they say so
Phil you say that stress is not good for
your body and there's lots of evidence
that stress isn't good for your body how
come when I go on a roller coaster on
Alton Towers or wherever I feel find at
the end of the day I feel will feel
great at the end of the day and the
latest research suggests that there is
what's called challenge and threat and a
challenge is something you think you
know I could probably deal with that
it's kind of you know I'm going to get
my head around it but I've got what's
needed threat is where you feel like I'm
not sure I can deal with this so long
term stress when we get into long-term
stress it has a number of very
well-documented effects on our body
it was suppresses our immune system
stops us being able to fight infection
which of course it's really important at
this time you know if there if we do
come across the virus the virus is
whatever it is the question is what is
our immune system like what can we do to
boost that to give us the best chance of
making this a mild infection rather than
the serious one and that's why stress is
significant it's quite easy to change if
you have the tools it's something a lot
of people unfortunately get into because
of you know the weirdness of the virus
the fear the panic in the media and the
isolation so Dell it's kind of a time
right for the possibility of illness or
the possibility of change it's it's very
interesting time a lot of your work a
lot of this mind-body connection and you
know information can play a part when it
comes to chasing dreams or just in
general living and creating life that
you love as you put it so what does it
mean to create and live a life that you
love so you talk about beliefs they're
absolutely beliefs are really really
really important so our beliefs do
really shape our physiology they also
show you what we think is possible so if
we think I'll never be able to do that
where somebody's told us oh you know you
know boys can't do that girls can't do
that tall people go and do that short
people can't do that quite often will
just absorb these things without
questioning them particularly if they
come from all thority figures and then
we live our lives through this kind of
slightly limited version of who we are
and what's possible so when we say get
liver
life you love what we're basically
saying is really look at what do you
want would be great for you what would
make you fulfilled and feel like you're
flourishing but also it's not healthy to
live a life that you don't like it
increases your stress it makes you feel
hopeless and desperate and all these
things that massively linked to poor
health and I think it's really
interesting when you talk about
authority figures because personally
from my experience you know if somebody
in a white coat it's you know tells you
oh well you can't recover from this or
this is chronic and it has a part to
play doesn't it absolutely it says again
these interviews I've been doing with
these research is one of the things I
often ask them is you know what's what's
your top tip from all the research that
you've come across you know and they're
really kind of sharp academics and most
of them say stuff like you know be nice
to people if you're a doctor spend time
be optimistic encourage hopefulness
because if you have I've seen this a lot
with people where a well-meaning
authority figure and often a doctor has
said you will never recover that's a
tough thing to fight because we're
trained to believe that experts are
correct if you're an expert most experts
will agree we're not right all the time
but as patients we just assume the
person in the white coat with the
letters after their name knows what
they're talking about and then we go
away with this well I never get better
and certainly in my experience many
people know about the story when I
suffered my hand and was told and nobody
else for me my hand again and I was
lucky that was like was quite contrary
and I really needed to move my hand
again so I could play the guitar and be
an osteopath than all the other things I
did and I went well I'm going to show
you that's not true but a lot of people
don't do that reasonably so and and it's
not always right to challenge expert
opinions either but it's like when when
you'll give them an opinion remember
it's an opinion maybe right it may not
be completely correct you need to
explore whether there are other opinions
that might be useful for you too I'm
still playing the guitar yes I am
to hit both of the pocket thank you so
much it's been an absolute pleasure
having you on the show today my pleasure
- great to meet you guys thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoy this
video and like a little bit more about
how the mind can heal the body and how
you can live the life you love and go
let me know in the comment section what
topics you want me to explore next week
and if you enjoy the video remember to
hit the like button see you next week